tonight as Idaho Police await
extradition from Pennsylvania they are
releasing very few details about their
investigation but police are confident
that the perpetrator is in custody so
how did they zero in on Brian coburger
here now with analysis Fox News
contributor and retired LAPD detective
Mark Fuhrman and Fox News contributor
and retired D.C police detective Ted
Williams Ted let's start with you you've
seen the big news of the day give us
your Top Line analysis of what's going
on
well you know uh Jason I got to tell you
I'm jubilated uh that they have uh been
able to locate a suspect in this case uh
I believe that uh with forensics as well
as the public tips as well as the the
latching on to that automobile and
possibly DNA founded that scene that led
to the arrest of all this gentleman
coburger uh I I have to believe that law
enforcement while they haven't given the
public much they have a great deal of
evidence that they're working with and
from and I think that or vehicle that
white vehicle that was confiscated in
Stanton Ohio uh stand to be corrected
Pennsylvania uh that that white uh
vehicle has a wealth of evidence and I'm
sure they are processing that white
vehicle as well as the other place
places that this guy stayed wherever he
stayed was a crime scene
yeah mark it was December 7th that
police put out a picture of the vehicle
that was supposedly taken outside of a
gas station about 3 45 in the morning
that's obviously uh one of the Clues
here but what else do you as a former
law enforcement officer what else what
are the other elements that have to come
together to culminate in in this arrest
well before they released a photo
they're going to work work the clue as
far as they can take the lead and
hopefully they can identify it so the
suspect doesn't get an indication that
they're on to him I think at this point
they've got DNA inside the residence
close to and in in contact with the
victims that can show that that DNA is
passed or that DNA is transferred from
one victim to victim four I think that's
absolute to coordinate three States a
federal agency two State Police agencies
of federal FBI SWAT warrant no knock at
three in the morning to coordinate all
that they're dead dead bang sure and I
think they've been on to him for about a
week I think this is something that DNA
might not have been as straightforward
as we'd like to think I I think that
they probably used just hypothetically
if the fall father was in the military
and they went to DOD CODIS type of DNA
his Y chromosome will be consistent so
they could at least eliminate we have a
guy with a white Elantra that goes to
Wazoo WSU and now we have somebody
that's father was in the military and
it's consistent with the owner of this
Elantra I think their attitude changed a
week ago the Pio Aaron Schnell said
we're getting a clearer picture of the
suspect and what happened at the crime
scene and chief Frye has done a few
interviews in the last week three or
four and he's been very relaxed and he's
been very confident and he keeps
hammering on the white Elantra I think
they didn't want the suspect to Rabbit
and I think that they've been they've
had eyes on this guy in Pennsylvania for
probably three or four days before they
served the warrant getting everybody
together everything signed buttoned up
and ready to go
uh real quickly only got about 20
seconds each for you what are we to make
that there is no evidently the the
murder weapon itself
Ted well I'll start first well I can
tell you the evidence of the murder
weapon on the bodies and somebody asked
to buy a murder weapon sometime even if
it's three years ago they either buy it
online use a debit card credit card pay
cash go to a in-person facility or buy
it online the absence of the knife is
almost more powerful than having the
knife itself
interesting Ted your thoughts real quick
I wholeheartedly agree uh I might what I
want to see now is is this guy going to
wave uh Expedition back to uh Idaho and
also one of the things I'm very much
interested in seeing is the affidavit
that has been sealed or for this guy's
arrest uh there's going to be a
hopefully a great deal of information
that we can use to try to find out what
happened here and who in fact was the
target as law enforcement has said
Mark Fuhrman Ted Williams thank you so
much for joining us on Hannity hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else